I can drink this is hard stuff I'm
Audrey I'm Jonathan there were siblings
we're brothers
this is my mommy and we're cousins
justin is my younger brother they're
cousins yes we're gonna be drinking
moonshine and slow motion well the first
time ever it looks like it hasn't been
made in a bathtub
I hope it doesn't taste like gasoline I
don't really drink it ever and what do
you like to drink everything empty
stomach - I know
exactly cheers Cheers go down up down
all right yeah make yourself oh cool oh
yeah ready cheer
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
that was not as bad as I expected tastes
like a frat party this much oh you old
thing I can't drink this whole thing
yeah it went down pretty smoothly
it is I'm getting bathroom cleaner want
to help me what do you know no no it
freaks me out a little bit he's I mean I
just think of an old skinny man in an
alley I'm not fan
I wouldn't reach for it actually I got
when I settled it I feel for her and
fuzzy
[Music]
we should eat something now
[Music]
Wow
[Music]